so what do people usually say when
you're about to give a public talk it's
to imagine that your audience is naked
right well I'm doing a different trick
tonight and I'm going to imagine all of
us about farmers and well it's not so
much different and our farmers do so
much more for us than simply feed and
clothe and provide us excellent things
to drink our farmers are an important
part of all of our communities
particularly our rural communities and
more than that they're a strong driver
of resilient economics I think about it
this way when a brewery buys hops from
me growing here in Minnesota 90% of that
dollar stays in our state compared to
just 10% when they buy from somewhere
else what that means is a lot that night
new percent means local jobs it means
tax revenue for better schools and roads
it means support for the co-ops the
mechanics all the support staff that are
needed for a farm to thrive and there
are best stewards of the land this quote
I think exemplifies what our family
farmers do for us and stewarding our
shared natural resources that land as a
community is the basic concept of
ecology but that land is to be loved and
respected as an extension of ethics now
they start do a lot of good stuff for us
and our family farmers are great we'd
all agree however the trends in
agriculture today are dire the average
age of a farmer in America according to
the latest agricultural census 58.3 of
all the farmers 33 percent are 65 plus
that's a little character of my grandpa
he's still farming and he's much older
than 65 but to put it in perspective
another important public service job
teaching average age of teachers is 42
our farmers are pretty old in this
country and unfortunately when they
retire when they retire if they retire
we're not really replacing them of all
the farmers that we added in this
country between 2008 and 2012 across the
entire United States see if you can
catch this difference we had a 2000
under the age of 30 I'm one of those
I'll be around
autographs and photos later if you'd
like but you know where our farmers are
getting older and we're not replacing
them what's going on here what are we
going to do and I think there's a reason
folks aren't coming into it and that's
priceless we're gonna go through a
couple slides like this milk this is the
retail average retail price of a gallon
of milk in the United States or dollars
49 cents how much do you think the
farmer gets dollars $32 32 we get in
with bread average retail types of bread
in America 349 farmer gets 12 cents and
so how are we supposed to have strong
local farms in this scenario what are we
supposed to do if there aren't any local
farmers left and this isn't just a
farmer problem it's not just something
for the few of us farmers to sort out
this isn't all of us problem this is the
rural and it's urban and it's statewide
in his nationwide so what do we do about
it I'll tell you that but first a story
the green movement we're all kind of
familiar started in the 60s planting
trees and now we've come such a long way
green is part of our day-to-day lives as
part of the day to day lives of fortune
500 businesses is the subject of
international treaties the subject of
presidential debates you and I we switch
our light bulbs we recite we use
reusable bags we participate in the
green movement each and every day yeah
and this is how we get to the idea the
food movement relatively younger but
also somewhat familiar I imagine you go
to the grocery store you see a sign that
says buy local
you go to the farmers market you go to
the coop you read books by prominent
authors the food movement to date could
be summarized as voting with your fork
right the idea is you pull a doll or
your wallet how you spend that dollar
affects the food system
it supports farmers was too home and
that's all well and good but where are
we going how do we get to our renewable
energy moment like the green movement
did and this I think is what we need to
do just voting with our fork is not
solving the issues that our farmers are
facing and so we need to do more than
that I believe we must move on from just
voting with our fork the voting with our
vote we need to take our dollars and
continue to spend them locally we also
need to show up at the ballot box for
our farmers this is bigger than just
buying local strawberries once the year
to pick your own this is a year-round
effort that we must make together to
make the change we need changes like
fair pricing for farmers that sounds
bets quotas Supply Management guaranteed
prices changes like fair and open trade
that means ending trade Wars and yeah of
course it means voting don't we all knew
that one already though for example it's
working hey is that just this year in
Minnesota we passed a historic first in
the country tax credit the beginning
farmer tax credit it incentivizes a
transition of land from the existing
generation to the next generation that
was done by a handful of us young
farmers we certainly don't have money
you saw that earlier we don't a
political experience but we showed up
and we made our voices heard and thanks
to the support of farmers and non
farmers alike
we got something incredible done here in
this state if we can do what anybody can
do it now I was all white and fuzzy and
feels pretty happy skeptics in the
audience you're here
that would be me if I were here skeptics
they're thinking wow what do we need to
change about our food our food system
armors are great we have unlimited food
and it's real cheap too isn't that great
well unfortunately and 80s and the 90s
in this country we went down a path of
policy that could be described as get
big or get
out and what get bigger get out means as
you maximize production while minimizing
costs on its face value that sounds
pretty simple however that shift turned
our farmers from a venerated class and a
valued class in our society into a cost
to be minimized that shift made it so
that my great-grandfather who supported
the family with six cows that same dairy
trying to support their family has to be
600 cows today 6000 cow dairies are not
unheard of what happens when there's
this one dairy farm in an entire county
where there used to be hundreds the same
could be said with corn or beans or
field crops what happens when it takes
10,000 acres for one person to support
themselves when it used to only take 40
we know what happens we read about it in
the news broadly termed rural decline
but schools close schools consolidate
post office is closed grocery stores
closed people leave the community
suffers and goes away I believe all of
us in this audience of ties for rural
Minnesota know this story well this is
not a problem that we can solve with
farmers markets and good intentions we
have to do more for our farmers policy
who got us into this mess and policy can
get us out American farmers are only
getting older fewer and poorer if
they're crucial to our state they're the
vibrancy in our rural communities
they're the drivers of economic growth
and stability and there are shared
they're our best protectors of our
shared resources of land water and air
so we have to do better for them so join
me would you let's fight for our farmers
you can see it we're already doing it in
Minnesota and then great success and
together we can do even more and we must
so we were voting with our fork before
and we want to keep doing that but if I
could have one idea for you to go home
with today's vote with your vote and so
to the end on the count of three
all of us to say it together are you
ready okay one two three pull with your
vote very nice thank you
I think you got